let's review a little bit of everything
we learned so far and hopefully it'll
make everything fit together a little
bit better and then we'll do a bunch of
calculations with real numbers and I
think it'll really hit the point home so
first of all if we're dealing with it
let me actually write down let me make
some columns so if we're dealing with so
let me let see the we could call it the
concept concept and then we'll call it
the whether we're dealing with a
population population or a sample so the
first is the the first statistical
concept we came up with was the notion
of the mean or the central tendency and
we learned that that was one way to
measure the average or central tendency
of a of a of a data set the other ways
were the median and the mode but the
mean tends to show up a lot more
especially when we start talking about
variances and we'll do in this video the
standard deviation but the mean of a
population we learned we use the the
Greek letter mu is equal to the sum of
each of the data points in the
population that's an I let me make sure
it looks like an I so you're going to
sum up each of these those data points
you're going to start with the first one
and you're going to go to the nth one
we're assuming that there are n data
points in the population and then you
divide by the total number that you have
and this is very you know this is like
the average that you're used to taking
before you learn any of the statistic
stuff you add up all the data points and
you divide by the number there are the
sample is the same thing we just use a
slightly different terminology the mean
of a sample and I'll do it in a
different color just write it as X with
a line on top and that's equal to the
sum of all the data points in the sample
so each of the X I and the sample but
we're assuming the sample is something
less than a population so you start with
the first one still and then you go to
the lower case n where we assume that
lower case n is less than the big n if
this was the same thing then we're
actually taking the the average or
retaining the mean of the entire
population and then you divide by the
number of data points you added you get
2n
then we said okay how far if this gives
us the central tendency it's one measure
of the central tendency but what if we
wanted to know how good of an indicator
this is for the population or for the
sample or on average how far are the
data points from this mean and that's
where we came up with the concept of
variance and I'll arbitrarily switch
colors again variance variance in a
population the variable or the notation
for variance is the Sigma square this
means variance and that is equal to you
take each of the data points you take
each of the data points you find the
difference between that and the mean
that you calculate up there you square
it so you get the squared difference and
then you essentially take the average of
all of these you take the average of all
of these squared distances so that's if
you take the sum from I is equal to 1 to
N and you divide it by n that's the
variance and then the variance of a
sample mean and this was a little bit
more interesting and we talked a lot a
little bit about it in the last video
you actually want to provide it you want
to estimate the variance of the
population when you're taking the
variance of a sample and in order to
provide an unbiased estimate you do
something very similar to here but you
end up dividing by n minus 1 so let me
write that down
so the variance of a population I'm
sorry the variance of a sample or sample
variance or unbiased sample variance and
that's why we're divided by n minus 1
that's denoted by s squared what you do
is you take the difference between each
of the data points in the sample minus
the sample mean we assume that we don't
know the population mean maybe we did if
we if we know if we knew the population
mean we actually wouldn't have to do the
unbiased thing that we're going to do
here in the denominator but when you
have a sample the only way to kind of
figure out the population mean is to
estimate it with the sample mean so we
assume that we only have the sample mean
and you're going to square those and
then you're going to sum them up some of
them up from I is equal to 1 to I is
equal to n because you have n data
points and if you want an unbiased
estimator you divide by n
- one and we talked a little bit before
why you want this to be an N minus one
7n and actually in a couple of videos
I'll actually prove this to you one I'll
prove it by maybe experimental using
Excel and then I'll which wouldn't be a
proof but it'll just give you a little
bit of intuition and then I'll actually
prove it a little bit more formally
later on but you don't have to worry
about it right now now the next thing we
will learn is something that you've
probably heard a lot of especially
sometimes in class teachers talk about
the standard deviation of a test or it's
actually probably one of the most used
words and statistics I think a lot of
people unfortunately maybe use them use
it or maybe use it without fully
appreciating everything that it involves
but the goal is what will eventually
hopefully appreciate all of all that it
involves soon but the standard deviation
and once you know variance it's actually
quite straightforward it's the square of
the square root of the variance so the
standard deviation of a population is
written as Sigma which is equal to the
square root of the variance and now I
think you understand why variance is
written as Sigma squared and that is
equal to just the square root of all
that it's equal to the square root I'll
probably run out of space of all of that
so you know the sum I won't write the
top of the bottom that makes it messy if
X I minus mu squared everything over N
and then if you wanted the standard
deviation of a sample and it actually
gets a little bit interesting because
the standard deviation of a sample which
is equal to the square root of the
variance of a sample it actually turns
out that this is not an unbiased
estimator for this and I don't want to
get too technical for it right now that
this is actually a very good estimate of
this the expected value of this is going
to be this and I'll go more about I'll
go it into more depth on expected values
in the future but it turns out that this
is not quite the same expected value as
this but you don't have to worry about
it for now so why even talk about the
standard deviation well one the units
work out a little better if if let's say
all of our
data points were measured in meters
right if we were taking a bunch of
measurements of length then the units of
the variance would be meter squared
right because we're taking you know
meters - meters this would be a meter
than you're squaring you're getting
meters squared and that's kind of a
strange concept if you say you know the
average dispersion from the center is in
meters squared so well first when you
take the square root of it you get this
you get something that's again in meter
so you're kind of saying oh well the
standard deviation is X or Y meters and
then we'll learn a little bit if you can
actually model your data as a bell curve
and or if you assume that your data has
a distribution of a bell curve then this
tells you some interesting things about
where all of the the probability of
finding someone within one or two
standard deviations of the of the mean
but anyway I don't want to go too
technical right now let's just calculate
a bunch let's calculate let's calculate
let's say if I had numbers one two three
eight and seven and let's say that this
is a population so what would it what
would its mean be so I have 1 plus 2
plus 3 so this 3 plus 3 is 6 6 plus 8 is
14 14 plus 7 is 21 so the mean of this
population you sum up all the data
points you get 21 divided by the total
number of data points one two three four
five twenty-one divided by five which is
equal to what four point two four point
two fair enough now we want to figure
out the variance and we're assuming that
this is the entire population so the
variance of this population is going to
be equal to the squared the sum of the
squared differences of each of these
numbers from four point two I'm gonna
have to get my calculator out so it's
going to be one minus four point two
squared plus two minus four point two
squared plus three minus four point two
squared plus eight minus four point two
squared plus seven minus four point two
squared it's going to be all of that
that looks a little bit funny divided by
the number of data points we have
divided by the number five so let me
take the calculator out all right here
we go
actually maybe I should have used the
graphing calculator that I had let me
see if I can let me see if I can get
this thing if I could get this oh there
you go yeah I think the graphing one
will be better because I can see
everything that I'm writing okay so let
me clear this so I want to take one
minus four point two squared plus let me
write it down plus two minus four point
two squared plus three minus four point
two squared plus eight minus four point
two squared right I'm just taking this
the sum of the squared distances from
the mean squared one more plus seven
minus four point two squared so that's
the sum the sum is thirty eight point
eight so the numerator so this is going
to be equal to thirty eight point eight
divided by five so this is the sum of
the squared distances right each of
these just so you can relate to the
formula that's each of that is X I minus
the mean squared and so if we take the
sum of all of them right this is this
numerator is the sum of each of the X I
minus the mean squared from I equals 1
to N and that ended up to be thirty
eight point eight and I just calculated
like that I just took each of the data
points minus the mean squared add them
all up and I got thirty eight point
eight and then I want to divide it by n
which is five so this n up here is
actually also five right and so thirty
eight point eight divided by five is
divided by five is seven point seven six
seven point seven six so the variance
the variance let me scroll down a little
bit the variance is equal to seven point
seven six now if this was a sample of a
larger distribution if this was a sample
if the one two three eight and seven
weren't the population if it was a
sample from a larger population instead
of dividing by five we would have
divided by four and we would have gotten
the variance since thirty eight point
eight sorry thirty eight point eight
divided by n minus one which is divided
by four so then we would have gotten the
variance that we've gotten the sample
variance at nine point seven if you
divided by n minus one instead of n but
anyway don't worry about that right now
that's just a change of n but once you
have the variance very easy to figure
out the standard deviation you just take
the square root of it the square root of
seven point seven six seven six two
point seven eight two point seven let's
say two point seven nine is a standard
deviation so this gives us some measure
of on average how far the numbers are
away from the mean which was four point
two and it gives it in kind of the units
of the original measurement anyway I'm
all out of time I'll see you in the next
video well actually let's let's figure
out you know we said if this was a
sample if we were if those numbers were
a sample and not the population then we
figured out that the stand the sample
variance was nine point seven and so
then the sample standard deviation is
just going to be the square root of that
the square root of nine point seven
which would be three point one three
point one one anyway hopefully that
makes a little bit more concrete we've
been dealing with these Sigma notation
variables and all of that so far so when
you actually do it with numbers you see
it's hopefully not that difficult anyway
see you in the next video